turn around gotcha hi I'm Lee West for
Wired magazine now any gamer knows that
a slow computer is about as useful as an
ashtray on a skateboard hp's Blackbird
double O 2 is one of those rare kind of
birds
like corporate sky repair this thing is
fast it's cool and it's totally in
control until recently HP was about as
cool as you know I pack clipped on your
belt buckle for ladies to look at HP
just bought budu PC which is a gaming
computer company which makes computers
stronger faster and with more dynamic
design now the company is combining its
muscle with this Buddha the design art
deco style looks pretty cool but better
have insurance because this thing is
fast I mean you hop right inside of that
thing and next thing you know you're in
the autobahn plus the LED lights I'll
keep you company when you're kind of
afraid of the dark so what's cool about
this thing it's just liquid cooled the
cooling system goes throughout the
entire pc including both video cards so
you could feel free to crank up your
clock speeds without worrying about
frying your computer before you run out
of the house and go and get one you
might want to run back in and get a
credit card I actually take a second
trip and get to because the Blackbird
it's not a cheap date this thing will
set you back about fifty four hundred
bucks bottom line it's the best gaming
pc out there that's why we rated it nine
out of 10 for Wired magazine I'm Lee
West
you